[Music]
this is the second
worst day here
at iu north
yesterday conductor bannock
b-a-n-n-e-c
[Music]
wanted to send me home you're not even
short of breath
as yes i am
i was in so much pain from my neck my
neck hurt so bad
i was crushed he made me feel like i was
a drug addict
the ct went down a little bit into my
lungs and you could see new
pulmonary infiltrates new
uh lymphadenopathy all throughout my
neck
and all of a sudden yes bill treats your
pain
you have to show proof that you have
something wrong with you
i put forward and i maintain if that was
white
i wouldn't have to go through that
this is how black people get killed when
you send them home
and they don't know how to fight for
themselves
i had to talk to somebody maybe the
media somebody
to let people know how i'm being treated
up in this place
today we're going to be having a very
important yet difficult conversation
about racism within healthcare social
disparities within the healthcare system
and to see what actionable things we can
do to fight back i'd like to send our
condolences to dr moore's family and a
commitment that i'm going to make a
donation on their gofundme page
i'm linking that down below as well if
you'd like to contribute to
in order to have this in-depth
discussion i've invited special guest
dr khadaja ray a pediatric
anesthesiologist and
founder of the group physician women's
soar let's get right into it
the difficult part of having this
conversation after the fact
is that because of patient privacy rules
the institution cannot really adequately
say
what was happening what the results were
we can only go by the information that
was released by dr moore herself
my question to you is based on her
videos and her
writings on facebook how did the topic
of racism
enter the conversation and how should we
be thinking about it
when we're considering her own situation
yeah i think
um after a certain amount of time
of this treatment and this denial of how
serious her symptoms were as she
perceived them and as we perceive them
being told well you're really not short
of breath
i mean anybody watching that video you
don't have to have a medical degree to
appreciate
that she could barely finish her
sentences one thing that
we try to explain to people in the work
that i do
is that we know what racism looks like
just like a woman
knows what sexism looks like um there
are things
and peop the way people interact certain
things that are said
micro aggressions aggressions
um where you know what it looks like and
that's what she felt was happening and
she put that name to it
um she felt that it it became
or it was racially driven um and maybe
the doctor didn't even realize that was
driving him and we can talk about that
more later
but um there was you know after a point
of being mistreated and mishandled
she felt that it was racism and i've
seen uh
your response but with the physician
women's sore group
to the response that the organization
gave
as to what they thought was a breakdown
in communication
and one of the main things you pointed
out was that they did not even address
the word racism
in their response um ideally how would
you have had
uh that conversation say you were in
that position of authority
um overseeing this incident how would
you have used the word racism
what would have been the ideal approach
there well i mean i understand that when
you're in the shoes of a big
organization i'm sure they had their pr
people and their lawyers and everybody
else
um kind of helped craft that statement
but if i was in a position where i'm
making a statement and i want to have an
honest conversation you have to be
transparent and you have to
not take away what a person is saying
you have to listen to
what the person is saying we can't as
institutions
make pledges to do better to do better
regarding um
social justice racial justice and then
not
listen when you're being told that you
missed the mark
and i would just say exactly that dr
susan moore did not receive the care
that she
felt she should have received she said
that
it was due to racism and we are going to
do everything we can
to investigate this particular situation
and to educate our team and our staff
so that we can do better by the
community that we serve
we all have implicit biases and
unfortunately sometimes those implicit
biases cause issues in the work that we
have been um charged with doing to me
i see huge inequalities that happen
with communities of color access to
medications whether it's financial
or physical distance wise uh when i
recommend a healthy diet to a patient
do they actually have the ability to
acquire that diet
do they live in a food desert uh like
the fact that zip codes
are oftentimes more predictive of
someone's health than their actual
lab values all of these things are
partial
factors that doctors who think
holistically should be thinking about
their patients
how do we distinguish systemic
inequalities
that a lot of times were created because
of racism
in our past how do we distinguish
between issues like that
and situations like dr moore's
where racism seems to be a direct sort
of
uh claim against the people delivering
the care how do we balance those two
i think it's really is it's hard to
balance it too
um but we just have to be honest with
ourselves there's a harvard um
implicit bias test that i think every
everybody should take
most people are just shocked at really
what it tells them about themselves um
and i think that once we start having a
heart look at ourselves
doing active work to undo some of these
things
then everything kind of will work
together the systemic
issues versus the individual issues um
but we need to start with ourselves
individually
and then the institutions need to make
real commitments not just writing a
pledge when something's popular
in the media who are you hiring to do
this work
who's monitoring this information and
where do you start
i would almost maintain that once you
start having these conversations with
doctors who are already working who have
been in the field for 20 years
25 years who are at the hospital so it's
a little late i mean i guess it's never
too late
but we need to start much earlier in
medical school
having these conversations these classes
and really
unpacking this information in a court of
law you're judging an
action whether or not someone stole a
car or didn't steal a car when you're
talking about
racism you're talking about partially
intent and that requires
a lot of difficulty because unless they
outwardly say something or write
something it's almost impossible to
prove
so while that is the case i think people
take advantage of that fact
that they say oh you can't prove i was
being racist
well if someone with lived experience
who understands the microaggressions the
tropes as well as you do
we should trust that person to be able
to make that distinction
and even if it doesn't mean that it's a
a judicial ruling
it could mean as something as trusting
an individual to make the right call
right correct correct there has to be
some kind of accountability we addressed
that in the medium article where
the hospital systems across indiana made
a pledge to better serve the communities
and to start addressing on racial
justice within medicine
people have to start holding each other
accountable one institution
to the other and you know help each
other out
and we need to have these conversations
and really get to the bottom
of what drives us and drives our
decision-making
and and acknowledge that there's a lot
of data and literature
there open up the new england journal of
medicine
and find so many studies documented of
pain control um not being the same
amongst black
black infants having the highest
mortality
in the nicu black women not surviving
breast cancer at the same rate as white
women that's not because of their
genetic
makeup it's because of later diagnosis
not having the same treatment options
offered and by the time these things are
caught
it's too late the same with black men
and prostate cancer
the data is there it's not being made up
so if that's there and we know it then
we have to start
asking the question of the why how is
this happening
why are people of color not receiving
the same
types of physical exams as their
counterparts
um why why is that happening and then
try to do something about it instead of
then
when we get the result that goes into
this data in literature
saying well but how do we know i mean
it's there it's right there and we just
have to acknowledge it in order to do
something about it
yeah these disparities existing should
not necessarily lead us to say
well the whole system is racist at least
i don't think it should be labeled this
way you can disagree with me or agree
with me i'm curious actually
but perhaps to say these disparities
exist
we need to figure out why and if it's
because of
past racist medical research
past racist based systemic inequalities
of housing
of redlining that
inherently makes the systemic inequality
happen as a result of racism
not necessarily the fact that the
individuals involved in that current
system
are racist themselves you have the
systemic and the institutionalized
racism where
you have people who don't have um
a quality of living you know they don't
have the food available
and they're living in places where
there's chemical racism as far as the
environment
there's a lot of um people doing some
great work in that field
um and then you have the doctor who may
be
from some small town
who's never seen a black person and now
they're not
doing that physical exam the way they
should and they miss that this woman has
breast cancer i love that with this
channel
that we can perhaps put some pressure on
some of these institutions
how would you go about encouraging them
is a nice word of making a change
for both black patients black
communities minority communities
but also their physicians and other
healthcare workers we have to
put value on lives
we can't say that this one life that's
in this suburb
is more valuable than the life that's
here in this inner city
and without resources then you're not
going to have good doctors who are going
to want to go
work there because like you said they're
going to get burned out they're not
going to last they're going to leave
but until these institutions um
make a real commitment and say
these communities are just as valuable
as the next
and we have to find ways to put the
money in
so that we have the resources so that
our doctors and our
our staff are supported so they can do
the job that they need to do
it's a really it's a really tough hill
to climb
um and then once you get past that then
what are we going to do
internally to assure that we
have the skills and i don't mean just
the medical skills but
all the skills that we need to be able
to communicate
educate interact and serve the community
in which we're choosing to be in in
whatever institution that is
you've mentioned also some great
practical points for providers as far as
knowing your obligation being
introspective going past the science and
thinking about lived experiences and
communication
factors anything if if anything
do you think that you would say to
patients
uh perhaps minority patients who
um feel like that they would like to do
something
to improve the quality of their care is
there anything you counsel your patients
on
well you know it's interesting because
this question has come up a lot i am i
did a radio show for um a show in
minnesota
where people were asking like wait a
minute if this doctor couldn't advocate
for herself
then how are we supposed to when we
don't speak the language we don't have
the knowledge or the resources
but what i can what i try to tell people
is to
do your best to advocate for yourself
if a doctor is speaking to you and you
don't
understand what they're saying you know
what tests they're ordering why they're
telling you need to take a medication
ask them to explain it again until you
understand if you feel like
you are being mistreated then if it's an
option to seek another opinion or to
switch
doctors then do so if you
feel like you're not getting the care
and the treatment that you deserve
then know that you can get a patient
advocate
within the hospital to come and be by
your side to try to help you
navigate the system um
and then i would tell people if you feel
like you're not getting what you need
then maybe try to find a doctor
that you can better relate to if you are
a man and you feel more comfortable with
a male
physician then maybe seek that out so
that you're
able to better communicate and openly
discuss
your medical concerns um so that you can
get the care that you deserve
and this isn't an obligation for
patients it's our obligation to make
sure the patient
understands when you're listening to a
patient's reaction to your instructions
is the same when a doctor is performing
a speculum exam should be making eye
contact with the patient as well to make
sure they're comfortable
so it's the doctor's obligation and the
institution's obligation to make sure
the patient's getting good care
the reason we're giving these extra bits
or you're giving these tidbits
to patients is to go the extra mile and
it's not their responsibility to do this
we have to constantly remind providers
that
because they say well then why didn't
the patient advocate for themselves
well while they can and that oftentimes
fails as seen in dr moore's case
it's just something that i would tell my
family member
almost to expect the medical system at
times to fail
and if they're able to advocate and
educate themselves
they will statistically have better
outcomes and perhaps that
will not solve all our problems but it
can at least give some
um practical advice for those who
are interested in seeking it how do we
go about
talking about racism
historically and present without further
deteriorating the doctor-patient
relationship that exists between the
black community as an example
and doctors we can't put that
acknowledgement
potentially causing a problem back on
the community
that has been wronged so for sure the
talking about it and the conversations
the acknowledgement is not the issue or
the problem
of the black community okay so
we have to because we know um there's a
wonderful book called
medical apartheid that talks about how
these while the medical establishment
has
not documented a lot of the abuses
these situations these experiences have
been passed down
amongst our communities even verbally
for hundreds of years so
it's well known so what do we do
for example when we are now faced with
the covet vaccine and how do we get
communities to then say okay well i'm
gonna go
get this vaccine when um there's this
long historical
relationship where we haven't been
treated that well we've been tricked
many times
um it comes into education
having people who look like them who
they trust
providing that information and being
available to answer questions which is a
whole other conversation
about how uh we are under-represented in
medicine
and in medical school and why that's a
whole other conversation
but there are plenty of studies that
have been done
that show that black patients do better
with doctors who look like them instead
of saying that
those communities don't trust the
medical establishment
we have to change our speech and which
then starts to change the way we think
the medical establishment has not done
what they need to do
to earn the trust of those communities
so if i'm hearing you right just to
reiterate
in order for us to do better in the
medical space to treat our patients
because
ultimately as a whole we want to help
everybody we that's
the goal the oath that we take as
physicians as nurses
we need to do better in reaching out to
communities
creating more diversity within our own
groups
so that they can communicate better and
take this long road
to improving our ability to communicate
with the black community for example yes
that's correct
for example um you know you have primary
care doctors who say oh my goodness is
just so frustrating
mrs so and so just won't take the blood
pressure medicine or
won't take their diabetic medications or
you know they're just not complying
just don't you have to
have a conversation a real human
conversation and this can apply to any
patient really
the why why is that is it access
is it financial is it some kind of
belief system where they're afraid to
take the medication
if you really have an honest
conversation with yourself
as a physician did you stop and really
explain and assure that they understood
the importance of whatever it is
whatever treatment
test whatever it is that you're trying
to communicate did you communicate in a
way that they understand that you
read the body language to see was there
some kind of trepidation on the part of
the patient
and really get to the bottom of why a
good friend and colleague of mine dr
judy washington actually works with the
sdfm
organization to increase diversity in
medicine to have this conversation
they actually have an underrepresented
minority fund to help with
scholarships is this the sole solution
or do we need to think
past scholarships past admissions
is there something we're missing here
that we haven't yet tried oh
boy dr mike that's a whole other segment
um yeah i mean it does go past the
scholarships by that time
it's almost too late um we have to start
by figuring out what's going on in the
public school system what's going on in
the inner
cities what's happening with the stem
programs in those schools and those
children when they're in elementary
school
um they don't have the resources and i
think covet
has exposed a lot of those disparities
people don't even have computers or
access to wi-fi
in the internet so how could they
possibly
um you know get involved in and do what
they need to do for some of these
classes and programs
and you know there are issues at the
the primary school level the inner city
schools and we are missing
potential doctors because they're just
not being fostered they're going to high
schools
don't have a strong ap program if you
don't have ap
classes or honors classes then how are
you going to get into a competitive
college
so it goes back to that
institutionalized racism
that nobody likes to discuss but is
certainly there
and where there are children all over
this country
who don't have the same opportunities
and while their minds
and their capabilities are just like
others
and there's nothing there to foster it
they don't have the programming
and so they don't have those
opportunities to even go to a college
that would be competitive enough to
prepare them
i grew up in the inner city south side
of chicago
and there's a program that's been around
for a very long time
since the 70s called the champs chicago
area health and medical careers program
and it was housed over at the iit
um there's a college iit on the south
side of chicago
and that was what their program was all
about
taking young children who had some kind
of propensity or
interest in science and math and
following
them all the way through high school all
the way to medical school
and without a program like that coming
from the inner city
i don't think i would be sitting here
with you today that's such a
sad point to hear but an important point
to hear
that young folks are trapped in this
vicious cycle
that either they're not exposed to good
education early on
or even if they have interest early on
their communities are not set up to
foster
that sort of enthusiasm or
they get pulled into crime ridden
communities
and as a result they lose focus on their
education
it's not a knock at all on stfm and the
scholarships and the amazing work that
they're doing
it's just showing that while that is
part of what we need to do
there's this whole other under address
section
of the beginning of how we get students
to get these scholarships and the
reality of the fact when we look at a
lot of the assistance programs that we
have
even in my hospital where i work a lot
of them go
unclaimed and it's partially because
our lack of communication it's because
failed communication and because we're
not addressing that initial stage that
you talked about
of starting people up to know that these
programs exist
to get them excited about becoming a
pediatric anesthesiologist like yourself
and that initial start is such an
important place to talk about and focus
on
that i really hope as we move forward in
the era of investing
into health care into children we really
think about
that educational aspect and i hope
that's where a lot of change happens
i'm one of those perhaps naive believers
that if with education you could change
almost
everything if you have an educated
patient
in that it won't solve every problem
it'll improve their outcomes
if you have education to young folks
they'll be excited to be providers and
then be providers for the people
who perhaps look more like them and have
better outcomes
so i really would like to see more
incentivization
early on as opposed to going to high
school solely and saying
well if you go we can give you this
scholarship that early on aspect is
something i'm really passionate about as
well
yeah i think i mean i think it's great
those scholarships and the scholarships
like the one that your friend is doing
is important and again all things like
that is what
allowed me to get through the system and
many of my friends
so it's all very important we just have
to
continue to look at every level um
because we're missing out
on a lot of people who could uh
do very well um but they're just not
given the opportunity and they don't
have that access
i know we covered a lot i'd love to
leave you with the last word
what do you think should be the ultimate
message to the million plus people
hopefully that will watch this video
i think that um i would just like to
impart on people that
the discussion about race is a very
difficult
discussion but it's one that's necessary
and people are dying and people are
dying
needlessly so because of just
because of the color of their skin and
that's
unacceptable we have to reach out to our
neighbors
and try to understand each other have
conversations get to know each other
and don't deny other people's
experiences
my condolences go out to dr susan
moore's family
and we lost a big part of our medical
community
and i think that we should all walk away
from that
just remembering that when somebody when
a
a black person or a person of color or
whatever the situation is when somebody
speaks and they're saying something
we have to listen um she knows what
she knew what racism was she called it
and it may have possibly
cost her her life i
say that dr moore passed away
due to two things two pandemics the
pandemic
the covet pandemic and the racism
pandemic
we have to have these conversations
so that we can take that off of the
table and people
need to be treated fairly we know what
our
experiences are and just because you
have not experienced it
you have to approach these conversations
with an
open heart and ear and have some empathy
so that we can get some real change
thank you so much dr ray i'm linking all
of your information down below where
people can find you
your physician soar group and to
continue their education
much like i need to do in reading
medical apartheid
other resources to continue learning
because we're all imperfect
we all have implicit biases and i thank
everybody for watching
and dr ray for her wise words and advice
[Music]